what's happened to males in education
what's happened is that males have
fallen rapidly behind females at every
stage of the education system in every
Advanced economy in the world there are
more young women with a college degree
than young men in both the UK and the US
and pretty much every measure you can
look at girls are ahead of boys in most
places now the girls and women have
caught up in math and science as well
and in some cases overtaker and still
have this huge lead in literacy in
English it's really interesting go back
and you read the stuff in the 70s when
we were really pushing for gender
equality in education to get more women
into college and especially into more
male dominated subjects and everybody
was pushing towards parity nobody
predicted once girls and women caught up
with boys and men that they would keep
going and that we would now have a big
agenda Gap in higher education than we
did 50 years ago just the other way
around and can only be the result of
structural factors if it's happening
everywhere and every level is not the
kid it's as a structural problem with
the education system that's just not
male friendly enough